on est dans une situation où à mon avis
il faudrait mettre sur la table
cette question simple ce problème simple
est-ce que le contrôle d'identité ne
devrait pas être aboli c'est à dire est
ce qu'il est normal que lorsqu'une
personne marche dans la rue elle puisse
de manière absolument arbitraire être
arrêté par un agent des forces de
l'ordre et qu'on lui demande de décliner
son identité
cela dans les pays anglo saxons dans les
pays où il ya ce qu'on appelle l'habeas
corpus est à dire la possession de son
propre corps et biens cela n'existe pas
ou en tout cas cela exige des
infractions sur l'exigent des mesures
exceptionnelles
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas posé la
question de savoir si nous sommes nous
mêmes des personnes dont le corps
devrait être au même titre que le
domicile également au même titre que les
biens inviolable est-ce que c'est ces
affaires qui peuvent déraper en violent
comme on l'a vu dans la sphère théo est
ce que on ne devrait pas être protégé
que un type simplement parce qu'il a un
badge puissent venir vous voir vous
palpez demandé de décliner votre
identité et c est ce qu il faudrait pas
que tout cela exige une enquête existe
comme on dit en anglais mme probable
cause c'est à dire que on soit dans une
situation vous est suspecté
véritablement de quelque chose et que
cet arbitraire qui consiste à pouvoir
choisir n'importe qui et le procédé avec
lui de manière absolument arbitraire à
n'importe quel examen
est-ce que cela n'est pas quelque chose
de fondamentalement foncièrement
antidémocratique
moi je pense je pense que ces histoires
de traçable de traçage de traçabilité du
contrôle d'identité dont on parle tout
bon ce n'est pas suffisant cette
histoire de caméra ventrale dont parle
le ministre de l'intérieur ce n'est pas
suffisant mais qu'on pourrait vivre dans
une société tout à fait vivable tout à
fait raisonnable dans laquelle le
contrôle d'identité tout simplement
n'existe pas et en contrôle simplement
des personnes qui sont effectivement
erea est réellement des suspectes
car cette mesure du contrôle d'identité
à mon avis le péché originel du racisme
structurel de la police est à dire c'est
ce qui constitue son droit au racisme
à
[Musique]